the gritty world of the batman is filled
with intrigue and corruption but as a
credits role there is a lot left
unresolved keep watching to learn the
biggest unanswered questions from the
batman
perhaps the biggest tease for batman's
future clash with villainy is a
mysterious character sitting in the cell
right next to the riddler at the end of
the film he offers a riddler friendship
or an alliance in an effort to stage a
comeback story for the people of gotham
at first glance it seems like the figure
might be some kind of revamped take on
twoface his hair is unkempt and it
appears that his face may be disfigured
at least on the one side that the
audience is allowed to see furthermore
batman fans will recognize that carmine
falcone's operations were busted wide
open by law enforcement prior to the
events of the film in jeff loeb's a long
halloween it's falcone's legal woes and
his rivalry with salmaroni that result
in harvey dent being splashed with acid
by a mobster during his testimony in
court this could have already occurred
prior to the batman especially since gil
coulson is the da and there is no
mention of harvey dent however that
cackle isn't necessarily something
twoface is known for in fact it's far
more reminiscent of the joker
just an old friend who's dying to do me
a favor
[Music]
[Laughter]
the riddler is very thorough when he
goes combing through the history books
of gotham city in an attempt to
eliminate every bit of corruption he can
find the riddler's mission becomes clear
kill a corrupt official then destroy
their reputation by outing their dirty
deeds on the nightly news during his
vigilante crusade he targets the wayne
family among his newspaper clippings is
one that highlights a seeming
partnership between thomas wayne and
crime boss carmine falcone and in that
stack one headline can be seen
referencing edward elliott the riddler
clearly out his eye on the wayne and
arkham families who helped establish
gotham city however edward elliot was
also a wealthy aristocrat who played a
fundamental role in modernizing the city
in the comics he's an ancestor of thomas
elliot who was bruce wayne's friend when
they were kids he later turned to a life
of crime adopting the moniker of hush
and using his talents and medical
expertise to wage war against bruce
underneath it all thomas was envious of
bruce's life despite the tragedy that he
suffered in crime alley as a young boy
this villain's nefarious deeds are
ultimately very personal for batman as a
result
now that we know the elliot family
exists within the gotham city of the
batman there's always a chance that hush
could take center stage
the riddler highlighted two of gotham's
most elite families the waynes and the
arkhams during the riddler's crusade
against the corrupt powers in gotham he
discusses thomas wayne's culpability for
working with the mob and associating
with the likes of carmine falcone even
though riddler brings up the two
families he really only focuses on the
wanes and their closeted collaboration
with organized crime
you're part of this too
you'll see
[Music]
the arkham family is never discussed in
great detail is the arkham family still
active in gotham or is a famous holding
asylum that bears their family name the
only real claim to fame clearly the
riddler didn't attack anyone within the
arkham family that could be because
they're lineage is no more all because
the living arkham family members are
squeaky clean perhaps batman's next foe
will teach us more about what happened
to the arkhams
the riddler made his capture rather easy
clearly he had an end game in mind that
the gotham police department wasn't
privy to and neither was batman despite
the riddler's attempts to enlighten him
when we see the riddler sitting on the
opposite side of hardened glass talking
to batman about his plan viewers can see
clearly that he has an arkham state
hospital suit on why is the facility not
referred to as arkham asylum will the
state hospital undergo changes after a
new surge in high-profile villains make
their way into police custody after
being captured by batman in the film
joker joaquin felix's version of the
character is seen standing outside of
arkham state hospital as well perhaps
this is also the version of arkham we
see in the batman
alfred pennyworth is the closest bruce
wayne has to a family in most iterations
of the character he is a faithful butler
who served the family for many years he
helped care for bruce following the
tragic death of his parents in the
batman alfred receives the wrath of the
riddler by mistake as a male bomb
detonates the lethal package was
actually meant for bruce fortunately
alfred manages to survive
although he's hospitalized in critical
condition later alfred reveals that he
was the one who taught bruce to fight as
evidenced during the fight sequences
seen in the batman those lessons must
have included a whole lot more than
simply how to throw a punch if batman's
combat prowess has any indication alfred
is a formidable fighter bruce's
confidant also tries to help him come to
terms with feelings of guilt over his
parents deaths he reminds a crime
fighter that he was a young boy at the
time alfred explains that he was the one
responsible for protecting them does
that mean alfred acts more like a
bodyguard than a butler in the earth one
comic book storyline alfred is a
battle-hardened fighter who trained
bruce in all that he knows as a former
member of the sas our friend likely knew
a thing or two about combat and survival
perhaps the alfred we see in the batman
shares a similar backstory
make no mistake batman can take a
beating that's in no small part thanks
is apparently stellar armor although we
don't really know exactly why batman's
suit is so good at repelling damage
there's obviously a heavy degree of
kevlar involved batman takes several
bullets throughout the film including a
shotgun blast directly to the chest and
he somehow manages to walk away every
time that raises the question what is
batman's armor made of kevlar can only
do so much it's pretty clear that bruce
has some top-of-the-line gear for
example he wears a pair of contacts that
work as spy cameras capable of recording
everything he sees at one point in the
film he has to escape the police from
inside the precinct he and jim gordon
stage a faux assault and batman flees to
the top of the building where he leaps
from the roof to glide safely away from
danger he doesn't exactly land
gracefully however his parachute catches
a bridge and slams his body into a
vehicle and the concrete it's a pretty
nasty spill and he limps away in a
significant amount of pain however the
whole engagement makes us wonder what
type of armor could possibly protect
batman from colliding at a high speed
with concrete and metal
fans know well that batman prepares for
just about any probable scenario
he often has access to a variety of
tools or gadgets that he might need to
rely on in a pinch in order to narrowly
avert catastrophe in the final moments
of the film batman is fighting several
of the riddler's followers who are all
armed to the teeth one particular baddie
knocks the wind out of the dark knight
with a rather close-range shotgun blast
batman is visibly injured and likely
suffering from fractured ribs selena
kyle enters the fray to save batman but
quickly finds herself taking heat from
another goon in an effort to save selena
batman pulls out a strange green fluid
and injects himself with him after which
he gets up and pummels his foe in a fit
of rage now what do we know about a
green fluid that bolsters physical
performance dramatically and might even
cause someone to lose control of their
anger bane might know the answer to this
question because in the comics venom is
the name of a drug the backbreaking
villain uses in an attempt to overpower
batman the question the batman viewers
are left asking is was that vial filled
with venom if so why would batman be
carrying him
at the start of the batman the penguin
isn't quite the high profile gangster
he's known for being throughout his rich
history in the comics when we first see
him he's still under carmine falcone's
thumb of course this changes when the
riddler murders falcone creating a power
vacuum in gotham's organized crime
structure that the penguin is poised to
take full advantage of at the end of the
film we see a shot of the penguin
contemplatively looking out at gotham
it's clear that he's about to ascend the
ranks of his criminal empire so what
does the future hold for the penguin
after the credits roll does this
position him to be a prime target for
batman in an upcoming sequel at some
point we'll be treated to a look at the
penguin prior to the events of the
batman with his own spin-off series on
hbo max perhaps the show will shed some
light on the character's plans for the
future
batman's partnership with the gcpd and
more specifically jim gordon is one of
the most famous aspects of the dark
knight's legacy in times of trouble
police commissioner jim gordon often
flips on the bat signal summoning the
caped crusader but in the batman jim
gordon is still a lieutenant and hasn't
yet risen to the position of police
commissioner that role belongs to pete
savage unfortunately for the
commissioner however his dirty deeds are
brought to light by the riddler rather
quickly the villain releases a snuff
film of sorts putting savage's demise on
full display with murder and mayhem on
the agenda for gotham there isn't any
time to discuss replacements for the
corrupt commissioner during the events
of the batman however when the dust
settles perhaps gordon will be promoted
to the job he's most famous for it's not
a foregone conclusion though there are
those in the police force who don't
condone jim's work with batman still it
seems like a safe bet that will see
gordon climb the ranks in a sequel
opening more doors for the blossoming
partnership between the dark knight and
gotham's police commissioner
coming from an affluent family bruce
wayne has always enjoyed the luxuries of
wayne manor he uses his family's private
estate as a bunker-like home base for
his personal professional and
crime-fighting operations however the
mansion is curiously absent from the
batman instead bruce seems to live in a
skyscraper looking down upon the city of
gotham his bat cave appears to be in an
abandoned subway tunnel this raises the
question of whether wayne manor exists
in matthew's version of the batman
mythos at one point riddler voices his
disdain for bruce wayne as a wealthy
orphan who had everything he claims
bruce looked down upon the less
fortunate suggesting that he may have
always lived in the skyscraper in gotham
city
my family has a history of philanthropy
but as far as i can tell you're not
doing anything
however if wayne manor and the bat cave
do exist perhaps they're undergoing
renovations much like in the dark knight
following raj al ghul's assault on the
wayne home there's also potential for
bruce to build a new home that's
strategically placed over a cave he can
utilize for his operations
the answer to this question varies
depending on which version of the batman
story you read watch or hear in some
versions thomas and martha wayne was
simply in the wrong place at the wrong
time the man named joe chill is often
referenced in batman lore as the third
who gunned down bruce's parents other
versions of the story indicate that the
mob played a role in thomas and martha's
deaths in the batman bruce confronts
carmine falcone over the deaths of his
parents he learns a hard truth carmine
claims thomas wayne came to falcone
asking him for his help in dealing with
a reporter spreading harmful information
about martha falcone in a calculated
move had the reporter killed but as he
goes on to tell bruce he's also heard
that his rival salmaroni had bruce's
parents murdered brucen approaches
alfred with this knowledge and alfred
claims that thomas didn't realize
falcone would help him by actually
having the reporter killed
he lied to me
burdened with guilt he resolved to go to
the authorities but was killed that
night he planned to do it this leads
bruce to believe that it was falcone who
killed his parents for his part alfred
admits that he hoped to find a smoking
gun identifying the guilty party but was
never able to do so he can't confirm
whether falcone did the deed with
falcone dead at the end of the batman we
won't hear more from him about it if
another player wants it involved it'll
likely play a pivotal role in brewster's
future conflicts with the evil that
plagues gotham
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]